all right we've got a few clouds hugging
the mountains up there but uh boy the
view of lee canyon just so pretty did
get a little fresh snow up there on the
mountain it is gorgeous this morning
with sunshine we have another
opportunity next week to get some more
snow california's got a lot of
opportunity next week we'll talk about
that in a minute let's get to
temperatures if you're just heading out
the door find a warmer coat maybe even
some gloves make sure the kids have on
something warm before they head out this
morning we're in the 40s but seven hills
mountains edge southern highlands in the
30s this morning upper 30s and 34 out at
red rock 20 up there at kyle canyon
teens at lee canyon how do we do on rain
well didn't do as much as we thought we
hoped it would be better yesterday's
rainfall we had trace amounts several
times through the day and the evening we
are still way behind for the year should
be close to four inches in the rain
bucket officially we just have a little
more than an inch and a half now we did
have measurable rainfall and quite a few
neighborhoods around the valley from
boulder city to the valley out to the
west side two tenths of an inch out at
red rock over a quarter of an inch up in
the moapa valley so that's great news
and as i said a few inches up there at
lee canyon the system now is to the
south of us along with the cold front
but a series of storms will move in next
week to california we'll get in on at
least one of those mammoth mountain
open for business top to bottom top to
bottom
you can see the snowplows were out
oh my goodness they had at least eight
inches from the storm that blew through
yesterday and they are bragging they've
been open since halloween weekend and
boy they've got more snow coming in feet
next week with the series of storms that
will be moving in to the west from the
pacific northwest so our radar was sort
of busy yesterday a lot of it was
moisture in the clouds that didn't
really fall we were misty we were windy
it was chilly but it's going to be
really cold tonight we've got freeze
warnings for most areas of clark county
clear skies and light winds tonight will
allow temperatures to settle down to
freezing or even to 20's in some
outlying areas so freeze warning goes
into effect at midnight
until 8 a.m tomorrow so wrap those
exposed pipes cover up those delicate
plants that are outdoors anything you
want to protect if you have citrus trees
make sure you want to cover those 33 up
on the mountain today with northwest
breezes is going to be cold up there all
day mid 50s for the valley and we'll
keep 50s through the weekend with sunny
skies but the nights are going to be
very cold next week late chance of rain
monday night best chance comes tuesday
with mountain snow slight chance left
early wednesday and then mostly sunny
skies and sunshine after that so
fingers crossed we get something again
next week